lors de son discours devant le congrès
le 3 juillet dernier et conformément aux
engagements qu'il avait pris devant les
français pendant la campagne
présidentielle le président de la
république a réaffirmé sa détermination
à réformer nos institutions pour les
moderniser les rendre plus efficaces et
permettre une meilleure représentation
de nos concitoyens dès septembre dernier
les loi organique et ordinaire pour la
confiance dans la vie politique ont
permis de clarifier les conditions
d'exercice du mandat de parlementaire et
de prévenir les conflits d'intérêts nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui porter une
nouvelle ambition qui requiert pour
partie une révision de notre loi
fondamentale dont la philosophie
d'ensemble sera bien entendu préserver
car il ne s'agit ni de revenir à la
quatrième république ni de passer à la
6e il s'agit bien au contraire de
revenir aux sources de notre vème
république une république dans laquelle
le gouvernement gouverne et dans
laquelle le parlement légifère et
contrôle pour ce faire des travaux
approfondis ont été menées par madame la
garde des sceaux en liaison avec le
ministre d'état ministre de l'intérieur
sur la base de ces travaux et à la
demande du président de la république
j'ai consulté le président de
l'assemblée nationale le président du
sénat et le président du conseil
économique social et environnemental qui
ont formulé des propositions utiles
j'ai également consulter l'ensemble des
groupes parlementaires
au delà des divergences politiques tous
ont insisté sur le nécessaire respect de
l'équilibré de notre fonctionnement
républicain et de notre parlementarisme
rationnalisé en particulier dans la
répartition des pouvoirs entre le
gouvernement et le par le vendredi
dernier le président de la république a
reçu ma présence le président du sénat
et le président de l'assemblée nationale
nous avons pu ensemble construire les
bases d'un accord possible
dès demain nous déposerons donc au
conseil d'état un projet de loi
constitutionnelle et dès la semaine
prochaine un projet de loi organique et
un projet de loi ordinaire
ces trois textes seront présentés
ensemble en conseil des ministres le 9
mai le président de la république m'a
demandé de vous en présenter aujourd'hui
les grandes lignes tout d'abord
s'agissant du projet de loi
constitutionnelle
il conforte l'indépendance de nos
juridictions avec le renforcement des
pouvoirs du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature pour la nomination et
l'exercice du pouvoir disciplinaire des
magistrats du parquet il organise
également la fin de la présence de
droits des anciens présidents de la
république au conseil constitutionnel il
modernise la procédure de mise en cause
de la responsabilité pénale des
ministres pour les faits commis dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions
procédure qui sera désormais du ressort
de la cour d'appel de paris et plus de
la cour de justice de la république
laquelle sera supprimée sur la
proposition du gouvernement et avec
l'approbation de l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires
un filtre sera toutefois conservé pour
que la responsabilité pénale des
ministres ne soit engagée qu'à bon
escient
le projet de loi constitutionnelle
procède également à une transformation
profonde du conseil économique social et
environnemental qui deviendra une
chambre de la société civile chargée
avec un nombre de membres réduit de
moitié d'organiser les consultations des
citoyens et des experts sur les projets
d'avenir pour notre pays le projet de
loi constitutionnel renforce
l'efficacité de la procédure législative
et l'effectivité du contrôle
parlementaire sur ce point le
gouvernement a pris en compte
l'opposition formulée par les présidents
des groupes parlementaires à l'idée d'un
contingentement
des amendements cette disposition qui
avait été envisagé a donc été retiré
mais les présidents des assemblées ont
convenu qu'il était nécessaire de
limiter les amendements sans portée
normative sans lien direct avec le texte
ou qui ne serait pas du domaine de la
loi
le projet de loi constitutionnelle
prévoit donc une disposition en la
matière sans revenir sur la réforme de
2008 qui a défini un équilibre entre une
semaine de contrôle une semaine
d'initiative législative parlementaire
et deux semaines d'initiative
législative gouvernementale les projets
de textes les plus importants ou les
plus urgents pourront bénéficier d'une
inscription prioritaire à l'ordre du
jour par ailleurs la procédure sera
accélérée après la commission mixte
paritaire
en cas d'échec de la commission mixte
paritaire même si la nouvelle lecture au
sénat sera maintenu enfin sur le modèle
de ce qui se pratique au sénat la
discussion en séance pourra être
focalisé sur les points principaux
grâce à un meilleur travail en
commission l'évaluation des lois sera
plus systématique et pendant les
semaines de contrôler les parlementaires
pourront procéder aux corrections ou au
simplification des lois faisant l'objet
de l'évaluation
le vote du budget sera plus rapide 50
jours au lieu des 70 qui prévalent
aujourd'hui mais un temps plus long sera
dédiée chaque printemps à l'évaluation
des politiques publiques et au contrôle
de l'exécution du budget par les
ministres il s'agit là de corriger un
décalage propre à nos instituts à nos
institutions dans lequel nous consacrons
beaucoup de temps à la discussion du
budget initial et très peu de temps aux
conditions de contrôle et l'examen de
l'exécution réel de ce budget le projet
de loi constitutionnelle marquera
également notre confiance dans la
capacité des collectivités locales de
métropole et d'outre-mer d'adapter elles
mêmes les règles qui régissent leur
domaine de compétence à la réalité de
leur territoire
cet impact girondins que nous proposons
aux territoires en suivant les
recommandations du conseil d'état
c'est aussi un gage d'efficacité et une
façon de réformer sans céder à l'esprit
de système
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république la corse
trouvera sa place dans notre
constitution ce qui permettra d'adapter
les lois de la république aux
spécificités insulaires mais sous le
contrôle du parlement
enfin le projet de loi constitutionnelle
inscrire à l'impératif de lutte contre
le changement climatique à l'article 34
qui définit comme vous le savez le
domaine de la loi
le parlement prendra ainsi sa part dans
ce défi majeur du siècle
le conseil d'état à l'occasion de la 6
in nous dira si le projet de service
national universel nécessite un
fondement constitutionnel pour valoriser
l'engagement des jeunes au service de la
nation
en ce cas l'article 34 seraient
modifiées de la même façon
s'agissant des projets de loi organique
et ordinaire conformément aux
engagements du président de la
république
les projets de loi organique et
ordinaire prévoient quant à eux une
réduction de 30% du nombre de députés de
sénateurs dans des conditions qui
garantissent la représentation de tous
les départements et territoires
l'introduction d'une dose de
représentation proportionnelle aux
élections législatives pour 15% des
sièges de députés à pourvoir
enfin l'interdiction du cumul des
mandats dans le temps
au delà de trois mandats identique
complet et consécutif pour les
parlementaires les présidents
d'exécutifs locaux à l'exception des
maires des communes de moins de 9000
habitants
l'objectif du gouvernement est de
permettre à l'assemblée nationale de
procéder à une première lecture de ces
textes avant la pause estivale puis de
parachever cette réforme en 2019
je veux redire que ces textes
contribueront à rénover profondément la
vie politique et parlementaire dans un
triple souci de responsabilité de
représentativité et d'efficace